ça se passe à la maternité le mec il dit
à la sage-femme il dit est-ce que vous
pensez que mon fils me ressemble et la
sage-femme elle dit oui mais c'est pas
grave s'il est en bonne santé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah bah c'est déjà le cas non mais c'est
deux mecs ils sont un peu bourrés tes
nanas dit je t'ai jamais posé la
question mais à ton avis ça pèse combien
un pet
mais tu dis bah ça pèse rien c'est du
gaz Elodie dit bon ben j'ai chié dans
mon froc
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
asting exactement gros casting on peut
vous donner la date mais c'est là c'est
là tu es bientôt on adore allez c'est le
mec qui dit à sa femme chérie pourquoi
tu me dis jamais que tu jouis
on est dans le 6 à 7
et sa femme elle dit bah tu m'as
interdit de t'appeler au bureau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et pour les enfants
donc c'est une grenouille qui a une
grande bouche et qui est très bavarde tu
vois et donc elle elle interpelle tous
les tous les animaux dans forêt voilà
reviens il y a un lapin qui arrive à sa
grande bouche ça fait bonjour toi tu
manges quoi toi tu t'appelles comment
toi
je m'appelle le lapin
mange quoi toi du coup je mange de
l'herbe un truc que j'adore par dessus
tout évidemment c'est c'est les carottes
quoi tu vois voilà son chemin le Cher a
rencontré bonjour toi
tu t'appelles comment toi
et là le le Cher il regarde comme ça il
dit ben moi elle m'appelle le cerf il y
a eu tu manges quoi toi
dis bon ben moi je mange de l'herbe de
la mousse l'hiver sous la neige quelques
branches d'arbres au revoir toi et là
elle croise le renard elle lui dit
bonjour toi
tu t'appelles comment toi et moi je
m'appelle le renard elle y est tu manges
quoi toi et ben ils disent que j'adore
par dessus tout moi c'est les
grenouilles à grande bouche et la
grenouille elle dit de voir beaucoup
plus
[Applaudissements]
vous savez ce que j'aime moi c'est que
tous les gars parce qu'on est en direct
à 18h58 c'est que tout le monde parle de
nous sur les autres chaînes il nous fait
et nous on fait des blagues avec
Jean-Marie
[Applaudissements]
alors parce que là on cherche des
propres ça va être dur tu as déjà
celle-là était magnifique
mais en mignonne je suis un petit peu
ça veut dire quoi i don't know Elodie je
sais pas
[Rires]
Jean-Marie